vanessa fragt könntest du dir vorstellen
auszuwandern wenn ja wohin
das kitz und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir eine
runde golf auf zeitpunkt nett und ich
hab mir heute ein paar richtig gute
fragen von euch stellen lassen es ist
jetzt gerade 20 nach 1 in der nacht von
sonntag auf freitag als gehört von euch
wissen wollte falls nicht sorry ich weiß
nie vergessen
und wo alter das war richtig los ok
warum habe ich die sachen mitgenommen
damit ich jetzt hier protection ab genau
deswegen
er bewegt sich bisschen schnell was habt
ihr jetzt vor ich will den erstmal
killen erst mal die beiden jungs hier
handeln bevor irgendetwas gemacht wird
alter wieder widerlegt sehr nicht mehr
schön gemacht was ist los mit dem kurve
lag das tier nicht mehr schön kommt du
bist es mal dauern so uno was ist mit
dem da diese der leon official der
gefällt mir wie gar nicht immer wieder
eckt alter schwede ok krass aber erstmal
hier zack zack zack die die rhj ist war
wohl nicht aus einem kit oberstdorfer
männer 000 hektar hektar heckt ok dann
lasst auch mal loslegen die erste frage
kommen von jackie pächter christian
welche stattfinden gefällt dir am
meisten und welche kann zu empfehlen zu
besuchen
also leute ist es nach wie vor so dass
ich einfach so ein bisschen in köln
verliebt bin ich kann nicht genau sagen
woran es liegt aber damals doch ich kann
das kann ich schon sagen damals ist
dieser youtube halb so riesig groß war
um köln herum habe ich irgendwann mal
ein herz gefasst und bin nach köln
gefahren und köln hat mich halt von
anfang an voll geflechten irgendwie ja
das ding jetzt schreibe ich aber mit ins
herz getroffen ist wirklich so es klingt
ultra schleimig älter aber ja irgendwie
habe ich mich dann so bisschen den
kölnern verliebt und auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht mehr ganz so blind verliebt bin
mag ich doch trotzdem hat die stadt
wirklich gerne was sie noch schöner
städte in denen ich war kopenhagen
gerade gefällt mir sehr sehr gut sollte
man ruhig mal hingehen barcelona auch
gut dass jetzt alles sehr klassisch
touristisch finde ich was noch freiburg
in deutschland ist übrigens auch ganz
schön echt sehr nice und alter was macht
er da oben läutete möchte ich noch
gebaut dessen so die städte die ich so
empfehlen
ansonsten war ich jetzt noch nicht groß
in der welt unterwegs muss man auch
einfach so klar sehen ok wack local der
not back alters instant weg okay aber
gut jetzt davon habe ich noch nicht
sicher bei zeiten geführt aber jetzt
kann ich hier schon in der besten
verfassung beantworten hektar question
wien gar die um leser fragt haste luca
schon einen vortrag gehalten
er ist mein kleiner bruder wenn du ihm
weh tut's billigt ich ja also ich war es
wisst ja dass das muss real ist das
wissen glaube ich einige aber es kam
tatsächlich bisher noch nicht so weit
dass ich zum lukas sagen musste dass er
auch max aufpassen soll und ihnen die
schlecht behandeln soll
weil ludwig weil er weiß genau dass wir
ihn hassen und er weiß dass gott ihn
abstechen wird wenn dann noch mal acht
damals auf der gamescom angekündigt auf
dem ios angekündigt naja wenn er sich
daran hält dann kommt halt ein messer
von job und danach falls job mit dem
messer kann erfolg hat kann ich ja noch
überlegen was ich dann mache
okay erzählt der sohn der mittel in der
mittel es ist auch eine meiner letzten
gegner ich bin auch cool matt komm wir
suchen noch eine frage heraus er aber
zusammenfassend den vortrag gehalten ich
dich wortlos luca selbst fragt herrscher
question bist du bald bei einer
mysteriösen veranstaltung in berlin
mit diesem komischen luca luka das ist
eine super frage denn ja ich bin bald in
einer mysteriösen veranstaltung in
berlin
mit diesem komischen luca tatsächlich
alter zwischen omega unternommen egal wo
ich werde mich da sitzt du schön
flugsuche überbauen
dann wird der da geklatscht haben also
bekannt gemacht doch ihre blöcke a das
reicht aber nicht mehr
also sieht mich nicht you can city bkk
hatte yahoo gerettet so was von knapp
gerettet alter abgesehen von der bg
nebeneinander schritte gehen so das wird
richtig quickie ja leute ich bin
wirklich in der veranstaltung mit luca
in berlin auf einer veranstaltung dies
auch wirklich geheim aber ihr werdet
dazu irgendwas erfahren ich weiß gar
nicht was ich machen soll
vielleicht brauchen wir hier über
wahrscheinlich nachdem ich dann runter
der kleine james p
aber was wenn wir jedes detail
resistance das ist diese sinnlose feier
resistance pforten wobei so sinnlos ist
die vielleicht gar nicht wenn er jetzt
lover einsetzen will habe ich eine axt
habe ich auch auf die 3 guck mal was der
grün hier oben vor hat so mein lieber
drei gegner gibt es noch dann da ist er
da desto besser läuft als ob fiona
fragen der kreis schon hast du
irgendwann mal vor dem profilbild zu
ändern oder verbindest du etwas damit
findest du es cool etc
da gibt es habe ich mein twitter profil
bild damit verbinde ich tatsächlich
einiges denn dieses bild da schließt
sich jetzt der bogen zu barcelona ist
auf der rückfahrt aus barcelona
entstanden zwar sind wir da durch die
pyrenäen gefahren weil wir uns damals
gedacht haben wenn man auf der hinfahrt
irgendwie 200 euro oder nicht 200 aber
sehr sehr viel geld deutlich über 100
euro vielleicht 150 euro für mauth
bezahlt einfach nur um durch fucking
frankreich durchzufahren es ist das
schlimmste leute fand niemals mit dem
auto durch frankreich wenn sich
unbedingt notwendig ist weil die
franzosen so dermaßen hin lang wenn es
um die maut geht es ist richtig krass
also wirklich und auf der rückfahrt
haben uns dann gedacht okay das hat mir
kein bock mehr drauf und wir nehmen
jetzt nur noch mautfreie straßen und das
hat dazu geführt dass wir durch die
pyrenäen gefahren sind und dann oben in
den pyrenäen lag einfach schnee das war
wohlgemerkt damals im april
in barcelona waren schon 20 grad und am
wasser ist klasse war halt wir kamen aus
barcelona 23 20 grad warm aber ok gute
story hat nicht so kann sie einfach
deine dinger rein klatschen es wird
ihnen nicht viel bringen
die vielleicht noch ein paar sex.com
feuer und dann das war so krass wie kam
aus barcelona durch die pyrenäen und in
den pyrenäen lag einfach schnee also auf
den pyrenäen das war so nico ist eine
soziale erfahrung man ist quasi eine
stunde aus der stadt draußen auf einmal
ist man mitten im schnee da hab ich
gesagt okay dafür muss ich ein bild
machen und so sieht man mich auf meine
mutter bild wie ich auf einer passstraße
in den pyrenäen war nicht mitten auf der
fahrbahn stehen und diesen tiefen blech
war wegklatschen was hat er für waffen
dessen holz werden oder er hat müsste
gleiche richtung haben wie ich okay ich
prophezeie ich probier's einfach mal ein
energy corp wollen greifen dann
funktioniert und kann die hätten ja
läuft ganz gut leute läuft ganz gut und
er ist weg alter sehr schön was ist
letzten mein energy corp und skills los
man nicht schafft die tatsächlich immer
öfter ich schaffte glaube ich
tatsächlich öfter als dass ich sie
verpackt richtig nice okay nächste frage
samuel kraft hat er fragt was war der
grund warum du mit youtube angefangen
hast das habe ich letztens bei let's
play together schon einmal erzählt aber
das haben wahrscheinlich einige
natürlich mitbekommen deswegen erzählt
es jetzt nochmal also warum habe ich mit
youtube angefangen die meisten von euch
wissen ja dass max also mein bruder vom
er angefangen hat und damals haben wir
noch zusammen in einem haus gewohnt und
deswegen habe ich natürlich immer
mitbekommen wenn maxim sich in sein
zimmer verschlossen hat und gesagt hat
bitte nicht stören ich nehme jetzt auf
und ich war davon irgendwie irgendwann
ist faszinierend ich war davon schon
schon fasziniert von der rückmeldung die
ihr von den leuten bekommen hat wie
seine videos ankam dankeschön lud auch
durch peter das war einfach keine ahnung
das war für mich fasziniert so wie es
für jeden faszinierend ist der sich mal
als als außenstehender als jemand der
nicht mit youtube vertraut dass mit
diesen zahlen auseinandersetzen es ist
vollkommen so real ist einfach so und
dann irgendwie habe ich gedacht okay ich
finde es irgendwie voll cool was er da
macht ich will es auch machen und dann
habe ich selbst angefangen mit youtube
paar monate danach max hat im august
angefangen ich im dezember so ging's los
mit meinem channel und heute läuft
besser denn je
darf man glaube ich sagen blockbuster
unter anderem auch dank der hacker
schaut ihr euch wirklich gut gefällt
die sache wurde ansprechen wenn ihr das
seht schickt mir unbedingt unbedingt
unbedingt noch einen sendungen für
diesen sonntag für die hacker das könnt
ihr entweder per youtube machen oder an
die e mailadresse die ganz oben in der
beschreibung steht ich werde euch ganz
oben in die beschreibungen
e-mail-adresse reinpacken schickt an
diese e mail einen link zu dem nicht
gelisteten youtube upload wo er das dass
hacker material eingepackt hat
reingepackt habt dann werd ich mir das
anschauen und kann es ein eventueller im
video reinpacken ganz cool ist sagt zack
zack so das will ich auch sagen und er
ist dauern wunderbar und da haben wir
noch ein gegner der ist da hinten
wie heißt der stein friese nice nice pro
das hat er fürs dorf weil semi
protection der helm würde ich eigentlich
mitnehmen protection die l
aber sonst ist hier nicht mehr so viel
kaffee gebrauchen kann
ganz ehrlich ich freue mich jetzt
einfach rüber habe ich genug blöcke nee
hab ich nicht pro tag alter mann bleibt
ist ein bisschen glas nämlich das ok
also leute packen das jetzt hier über
wobei eine frage kann man sich noch
aufsuchen bevor man jetzt hier von dem
gekillt wird am ende aber nessa fragt
könntest du dir vorstellen auszuwandern
wenn ja wohin
ja leute der gedanke auszuwandern ist
ein gedanke der linken eigentlich gar
nicht so fern
ich habe schon öfter darüber nachgedacht
einfach mal auszusteigen weil es
unwahrscheinlich viele leute gemacht
aber ich stelle mir das wirklich schön
vor das passiert in letzter zeit immer
öfter also je mehr man so gebunden ist
an den job und dann
ein praktikum und auch an youtube habe
ich einfach immer öfter die fantasie
dass ich mal dass man sie einfach alles
so alles also wirklich alles komplett
hinter sich lässt und einfach von vorne
anfängt ich finde den gedanken irgendwie
möglich faszinierend keine ahnung ist so
jetzt nächste mit 3,31 prozent auch
wieder
aber ich place immer zwei mann das ist
richtig dumm vor dem ball halt so easy
weglaufen kann
ok jetzt plätze er da hinten copper
project hier nicht ins loch fallen was
warum kriegt er falsch ein so junges
lauf doch nicht so ewig weg so sinnlos
es ist einfach nachts halb zwei wer
spielt nachts um halb zwei ernsthaft sky
wars mit dieser abfahrer strategie wie
dieser mensch darüber läuft die ganze
zeit weg das ist einfach so sinnlos wie
komme ich jetzt runter wenn du kannst
dann habe ich runter und er fällt selbst
runter sie okay und er lief noch bevor
er stirbt egal leute das war's von der
heutigen folge ich hoffe dadurch so weit
gefallen macht's gut und